We now start our discussion
of stochastic processes
by starting with the simplest
stochastic process there is.
This is the so-called
Bernoulli process,
which is nothing but a sequence
of independent Bernoulli
trials.
We let Xi stand for the
random variable that
describes the result
in the i trial.
The assumptions that we
make are that at each trial
there is a certain probability,
p, that the trial results in 1.
And in that case, we
usually say that there
is a success at the ith trial.
And the remaining
probability, 1 minus p,
is assigned to the possibility
that the random variable Xi
takes a value of
0, in which case
sometimes we say that
there was a failure.
Now, to keep things
nontrivial, we
will always assume that p is
a number strictly between 0
and 1, because otherwise, in the
extreme cases of p equal to 0
or p equal to 1, there
isn't really any randomness.
This process is something
that we have already seen.
We have worked plenty
of examples involving
repeated Bernoulli trials
or repeated coin flips.
We have solved several problems,
we have seen several formulas.
Here we will recapitulate
some of them.
But we will also start
looking at the process
from a new point of view.
Before continuing, let me
emphasize the assumptions that
come into the Bernoulli process.
One key assumption is
that we have independence.
The different trials
are independent.
The second assumption
that we make
is that the model
is time homogeneous.
What I mean by this is
that this probability
p of success at a given trial
is the same for all trials.
It does not depend on i.
So this process is as simple as
a stochastic process could be.
But nevertheless, it
can be used as a model
in various situations.
Sometimes it's clear that
we're dealing with a Bernoulli
process, but sometimes it also
shows up in unexpected ways.
In any case, the first simple
example could be the following.
Every week you play the
lottery, and either you win
or you do not to win.
And assuming that it is
the same kind of lottery
that you play each
week, the constant p
would be the same, the
probability of success.
And assuming a lottery that
is not rigged in any way,
whether you win on
one week, should
be independent from what
happens in other weeks.
Quite often, the
Bernoulli process
is used as a model of
arrivals, in which case,
instead of saying
probability of success,
we would say probably
of an arrival.
The idea is that
time is slotted,
let's say, in
seconds, for example.
And each second you're sitting
at the entrance of a bank
and you make a note
whether somebody
came into the
bank, in which case
we have an arrival or success,
or whether no one came
during that time interval.
If one here believes
that different slots,
different seconds, are
independent of each other,
then you do have a
Bernoulli process.
It might not be an
exactly accurate model,
but it is a good
first approximation
to start working with a
model of this situation.
Similarly, if you have a
server, a computer, that
takes jobs to process and
jobs are coming randomly,
you divide time into
slots, and during each slot
a job might arrive
or might not arrive.
And as a first approach
to a model of this kind,
you might as well employ
the Bernoulli process.
A final note, why is this
process called the Bernoulli
process?
Well, the name comes
from a famous family
of Swiss mathematicians,
the Bernoulli family.
And one of them,
Jacob Bernoulli,
did many contributions to
many branches of mathematics.
But an important
one was in the field
of probability,
where he actually
derived quite deep results
on a sequence of what we now
call Bernoulli trials.